Olá aqui o Dr aland Dutra médico há mais
de 25 anos e Hoje vamos falar sobre
algumas vitaminas que devem ser evitadas
antes de dormir porque podem atrapalhar
o sono isso não acontece com todo mundo
mas atendi casos no consultório de
pessoas com dificuldades para dormir por
causa de uma vitamina ou mineral que
estavam tomando à noite Claro Existem
muitos motivos para noites mal dormidas
E aproveito para recomendar que vocês
assistam aos meus vídeos sobre como
melhorar a qualidade do sono eu vou
deixar o link na descrição Mas voltando
ao assunto alguns suplementos se tomados
à noite podem realmente causar insônia
se o seu médico prescreveu uma vitamina
para tomar antes de dormir ele fez isso
por um motivo
específico baseado na consulta e se você
depois de assistir esse vídeo perceber
que algum suplemento que Eu mencionei
está relacionado ado ao início da sua
insônia é importante buscar a orientação
do seu médico para ajustar a conduta
agora se você está tomando uma vitamina
por conta própria pode ser que esteja
cometendo um erro que está prejudicando
o seu sono é isso que vamos entender
agora a primeira vitamina que pode
interferir com seu sono é a vitamina B12
muita gente toma B12 e não sabe disso e
claro como eu já disse isso não vai
acontecer com todos tem gente que toma
B12 à noite não tem nenhum problema mas
na maioria das vezes a B12 pode causar
dificuldades para dormir então
precisamos considerar que a B12 é uma
vitamina que atua na produção de energia
ela pode dar muita energia para você
então é melhor que seja tomada no início
do dia pela manhã isso porque ela
estimula o sistema nervoso e pode
realmente em alguns casos interferir no
sono se tomar da noite a a próxima
vitamina é a vitamina B6 talvez você
esteja se perguntando Mas por que a B6
afinal ela faz parte de muito
suplementos que são prescritos para
melhorar o sono mas existem dois lados
da B6 que eu quero que vocês conheçam a
vitamina B6 também conhecida como
piridoxina tem um papel essencial no
metabolismo dos neurotransmissores que
são substâncias químicas que transmitem
sinais no cérebro um dos papéis mais
mais importante da B6 é ajudar na
conversão do aminoácido triptofano em
serotonina a serotonina é o
neurotransmissor que influencia o humor
e o sono durante o dia a serotonina
promove bem-estar e estabilidade
emocional enquanto que a noite ela é
convertida em melatonina que é o
hormônio do sono então a quantidade
adequada de vitamina B6 é muito
importante para garantir um sono
saudável mas o outro lado que não é
muito falado é que o excesso de vitamina
B6 ou tomá-la sem necessidade também
pode ser problemático muita B6 pode ter
um efeito negativo e causar insônia
porque pode levar a uma superatividade
dos
neurotransmissores Isto pode resultar em
um aumento do Estado de alerta e
ansiedade o que pode dificultar o início
ou manutenção do Son
em casos raros doses muito elevadas de
B6 também podem causar neuropatia
sensorial uma doença dos nervos é uma
condição que provoca Sensações como
formigamento ou dormência que podem
perturbar ainda mais o sono se foi
prescrito para você tomar a vitamina B6
antes de dormir ou em qualquer horário
do dia e você notou que a partir desse
momento começou a ter dificuldade para
dormir é importante verificar com o seu
médico a possibilidade dessa vitamina
estar atrapalhando o seu precioso sono
agora vamos falar da vitamina D de dado
que na verdade um hormônio assim como no
caso da vitamina B6 existem dois lados a
deficiência de vitamina D está associada
a problemas de sono incluindo
dificuldade para dormir menor duração do
sono e acordar frequentemente durante a
noite os receptores de vitamina D
estão presentes em várias áreas do
cérebro e ajudam a regular o ciclo do
Sono Além disso estão envolvidos nas
vias que regulam a melatonina e
curiosamente a vitamina D de dado e
melatonina tem ritmos opostos mas se
complementam enquanto a pele sintetiza a
vitamina D durante a exposição à luz
solar a glândula pineal produz a maior
parte da
melatonina principalmente a no mas há
indícios de que tomar o suplemento
vitamina D à noite pode interferir na
produção de melatonina e afetar
negativamente a qualidade do sono em
algumas pessoas por isso a maioria dos
Profissionais de Saúde geralmente
recomenda que você tome a vitamina D
durante o dia especialmente pela manhã
ou após o almoço para imitar a síntese
natural do corpo pela luz solar para
otimizar a absorção da Vitamina D é
ideal consumi-la com uma refeição que
tenha gordura já que a vitamina D é
lipossolúvel
existem pessoas que na verdade se sentem
bem tomando a vitamina D antes de dormir
isso é muito individual ok pessoal o
próximo suplemento é o cálcio que é um
mineral essencial para várias funções
metabólicas no corpo mas deve ser tomado
com cuidado em relação ao momento do dia
e a combinação com outros suplementos
tomar cálcio à noite não afeta
diretamente o sono mas pode reduzir a
eficiência do magnésio o magnésio é
importante porque muitas pessoas tomam
para sentir o relaxamento e promover um
sono melhor sabemos que a deficiência de
magnésio está associado à insônia agora
se você tomar magnésio ao mesmo tempo
que toma o cálcio antes de dormir saiba
que eles competem entre si e o cálcio
pode prejudicar a absorção do Magnésio e
consequentemente afetar o seu sono
também importante entender que o uso de
suplementos de cálcio devem ser feitos
com cautela pois o excesso de cálcio
podem levar a calcificação de tecidos
moles como vasos sanguíneos e rins
aumentando o risco de doenças
cardiovasculares e pedras nos rins e
também de nefrocalcinose que é um
acúmulo de cálcio no parenquima renal
quando a suplementar ação de cálcio é
necessária deve ser feita com cautela e
a inclusão de nutrientes em conjunto
como a vitamina D essencial para
absorção de cálcio no intestino magnésio
que deve ser tomado em horário diferente
do cálcio para evitar interações que eu
acabei de explicar K2 a vitamina K2 que
direciona o cálcio pros ossos ao invés
de permitir o depósito em artérias e
outros tecidos E também o boro que
regula o metabolismo de cálcio e
Magnésio e apoia da porte a função da
vitamina D agora vamos falar de outro
suplemento a com enzima q10 ou coq10
normalmente Ela é bem tolerada pela
maioria das pessoas e possui poucos
efeitos colaterais no entanto Alguns
podem experimentar insônia quando tomam
a coqu 10 perto da hora de dormir por
isso na maioria das vezes é recomendado
tomá-la pela manhã ou à tarde para
evitar esse efeito negativo também é
importante lembrar que a qualquer 10 é
melhor absorvida pelo corpo quando
consumida com uma refeição rica em
gordura pois isso otimiza a sua absorção
outra vitamina que pode ter um efeito
negativo se tomada antes de dormir é a
vitamina C ela é uma vitamina
hidrossolúvel O que significa que você
pode tomá-la com água e ela é geralmente
bem absorvida pelo corpo em qualquer
horário do dia mas a vitamina C pode
causar desconforto se consumida com
estômago vazio especialmente em pessoas
que sofre de refluxo ou gastrite agora é
melhor evitar tomar a vitamina C antes
de dormir pois ela pode intensificar
esses sintomas estomacais piorar o
refluxo Além disso para algumas pessoas
a vitamina C pode ter um efeito
estimulante no corpo o que não é
desejável antes de dormir e pode te
deixar Alerta e sem conseguir pegar no
sono o próximo suplemento é muito
popular muita gente utiliza é ômega-3
vocês sabem que ele é muito importante
pra saúde do coração do cérebro dos
vasos sanguíneos e das células do nosso
corpo mas atenção tomar ômega-3 à noite
pode ter um efeito negativo para algumas
pessoas muitos suplementos de ômega-3
deixam aquele gosto residual de óleo de
peixe na boca o que pode ser bem cômodo
se você toma ômega3 antes de dormir esse
gosto pode ficar ainda mais forte quando
você se deita podendo até causar refluxo
outra questão questão é que ômega-3 pode
aumentar os níveis de serotonina no
nosso cérebro embora isso seja benéfico
como eu já expliquei esse estímulo pode
interferir nos padrões de sono se o
ômega-3 for tomado à noite para otimizar
absorção e Minimizar qualquer
desconforto relacionado ao uso do
ômega-3 é melhor tomá-lo durante o dia
preferencialmente no café da manhã ou no
almoço pessoal quero que vocês entendam
que nem todos vão ter esses efeitos
colaterais e que em alguns casos
específicos tomar algum desses
suplementos à noite pode ser necessário
por algum motivo que o seu médico
prescreveu então é fundamental avisar o
seu médico antes de fazer qualquer
inclusão ou alteração na suplementação
que você esteja tomando compartilhe os
vídeos faço bem a vida de alguém pode
mudar também
[Música]
can Muito obrigado pela sua atenção um
grande abraço um beijo no seu coração
Você é fera